[MUSIC PLAYING]
SHAUN RUTLAND: We saw
an opportunity in 2011
when mobile was getting
very, very exciting.
And that really gave us
the energy to start Hutch.
We are a mobile studio
based in London,
and a lot of the people in
the studio are petrolheads.
All they do is talk about
cars, so we're wholly
focused on racing games.
In the past, racing games
were typically very skilled.
And we're trying
to find new ways
to engage players of all skill.
All our games come
from gut instinct.
So we do a lot of
concepting and prototyping
with the game teams.
But the mission is to get
that game into players' hands
as quickly as possible.
Google Play beta program
is incredibly important.
It's part of the tools
that we use in order
to allow the team
to make decisions
so we can then start
moving from gut instinct
into more informed data.
ROBIN SCANNELL:
Google Play allows
you to go through beta
to your soft launch
right through to global launch,
constantly getting feedback
from users.
And this allows us
to look at real data
and make the best possible
game for our players.
During the soft launch
period of "MMX Hill Climb,"
we were able to utilize
store-listening experiments
to test different icon colors.
And we found the
best possible icon
gave a 20% boost
to click-throughs
in the Play Store.
SHAUN RUTLAND: "MMX Hill Climb"
is a traditional casual racing
game.
It has fantastic
social features.
And one of the things we
found through the A/B testing
is the harder we made
it at certain points,
the better it retained.
ROBIN SCANNELL:
Using A/B testing,
we were able to test
vehicle stability and track
difficulty for the
start of our game
in order to best
improve the user
experience for new players.
In one particular example,
we looked at the difficulty
of a particular level.
We found this
particular level took
over 60 attempts,
which was many more
than other levels in the game.
So this allowed us to focus
on making this level less
challenging for the
particular point in the game
at where it was.
Game analytics are so
important because they allow
us to get out of this room.
And when we're creating
content for updates,
we know what's been
engaging the players.
SHAUN RUTLAND: "MMX
Hill Climb" has
had over three million
players on Google Play.
We're seeing engagement times
of around 48 minutes per day,
so it's proven to be
very addictive, which
is super exciting.
ROBIN SCANNELL: Using
reviews can show us
problems that might
not necessarily
be clear in the analytics.
They can provide opportunities
for new content updates,
or they can suggest
that we've not
explained particular features
in the game particularly well.
SHAUN RUTLAND: Analytics is
incredibly important to us.
We've been able to improve
our first time user
experience in past games and
increase out LTV by two times.
Each year, we detain over
10 million new players
on Google Play.
We've seen revenues increase
in the last four years
by three times and engagement
is going up and up and up.
In the long term,
we're really focused
on making the best
place for developers
to work to make the best games.
We're trying to create
the studio of dreams.
[MUSIC PLAYING]